is it uh useful for us
to maybe first talk about how quantum
mechanics let's put
quantum mechanics into the world from
physics model yes
let's go there so we talked about
general relativity now
what uh what have you found uh
what's the story of quantum mechanics
right within and outside of the war from
physics
right so i mean the the the key idea of
quantum mechanics
the sort of the the typical
interpretation is classical physics says
a definite thing happens quantum physics
says there's this whole set of paths of
things that might happen
and we are just observing some overall
probability of how those paths work
okay so when you think about our
hypographs and all these little updates
that are going on
there's a very remarkable thing to
realize which is
if you say well which particular
sequence of updates should you do
say well it's not really defined you can
do any of a whole collection of possible
sequences of updates
okay that set of possible sequences of
updates
defines yet another kind of graph that
we call a multi-way graph
and a multi-way graph just is a graph
where
at every node there is a choice
of several different possible things
that could happen so for example you go
this way go that way
those are two different edges in the
multi-way graph and you're building up
the set of possibilities so actually
like for example i just made the one
the multi-way graph for tic-tac-toe okay
so tic-tac-toe
you start off with some some board that
you know as everything is blank and then
somebody can put down
an x somewhere an o somewhere and then
there are different possibilities at
each stage there are different
possibilities
and so you build up this multi-way graph
of all those possibilities now notice
that even in tic-tac-toe
you have the feature that there can be
something where you
have two different things that happen
and then those branches merge
because you end up with the same shape
you know the same configuration of the
board
even though you got there in two
different ways so
the the thing that sort of an inevitable
feature of our models is
that just like quantum mechanics
suggests definite things don't happen
instead you get this whole multi-way
graph of all these possibilities
okay so then the question is so okay so
that's sort of a a picture of what's
going on
now you say okay well quantum mechanics
has all these features of uh
you know all this mathematical structure
and so on how do you get that
mathematical structure
okay couple of couple of things to say
so quantum mechanics is actually
in a sense two different theories glued
together quantum mechanics is the theory
of
how quantum amplitudes work that more or
less give you the probabilities of
things happening
and it's the theory of quantum
measurement which is the theory of how
we actually
conclude definite things because the
mathematics just gives you these quantum
amplitudes which are more or less
probabilities of things happening
but yet we actually observe definite
things in the world
um quantum measurement has always been a
bit mysterious it's always been
something where people
just say well the mathematics says this
but then you do a measurement and the
philosophical arguments about what the
measurement is but
it's not something where there's a
theory of the measurement somebody on
reddit also asked uh
please ask steven to tell his
story of this the double sled experiment
okay yeah i can i said is that does that
make sense oh yeah it makes sense
absolutely makes sense why is this like
a good way to discuss
uh a little bit let me let me go let me
explain a couple of things first so
so the structure of quantum mechanics is
is mathematically quite complicated
um one of the features let's see how to
how to describe this
okay so first point is there's this
multi-way graph
of all these different paths of of
things that can happen in the world
and the important point is that that uh
these you can have branchings and you
can have mergings
okay so this property turns out causal
invariance
is the statement that the number of
mergings is equal to the number of
branchings yeah so
in other words every time there's a
branch eventually there will also be
emerge
in other words every time there were two
possibilities for what might have
happened eventually those will merge
beautiful concept by the way but yeah
yeah yeah so so that
so that idea okay so then
uh so that's that's one thing and that's
closely related to the
the uh sort of objectivity in quantum
mechanics the fact that we believe
definite things happen
it's because although there are all
these different paths in some sense
because of causal invariance they all
imply the same thing that's i'm cheating
a little bit and saying that but that's
roughly
the essence of what's going on okay next
next thing to think about
is uh you have this multi-way graph it
has all these different possible things
that are happening
now we ask this multi-way graph is sort
of evolving with time
over time it's branching it's merging
it's doing all these things
okay um the question we can ask is
if we slice it at a particular time
what do we see and that slice represents
in a sense
something to do with the state of the
universe at a particular time
so in other words we've got this
multi-weight graph of all these
possibilities
and then we're asking and and okay
we take the slice this slice represents
percent okay each of these different
parts corresponds to a different quantum
possibility for what's happening
right when we take the slice we're
saying what are the set of quantum
possibilities
that exists at a particular time and
when you say slice
are these you slice the graph and then
there's a bunch of leaves
a bunch of leaves and those represent
the state of
things right but but then okay so the
important thing
that you are quickly picking up on is
that um what what matters is kind of how
these leaves are related to each other
so a good way to tell how leaves are
related is just to say on the step
before did they have a common ancestor
so two leaves
might be they might have just branched
from one thing or they might be far away
you know way far apart in this graph
where to get to a common ancestor maybe
you have to go all the way back to the
beginning of the graph all the way back
to the beginning
there's some kind of measure of distance
right and that but the what you get
is by making the slice what you call it
bronchial space the space of branches
um and in this branchial space um
you have a graph that represents the
relationships between
these quantum states in bronchial space
you have this notion of distance
in bronchial space okay so it's
connected to
quantum entanglement yes yes it's it's
it's basically
the the distance in branchial space is
kind of an entanglement distance
so this is a very nice model right it is
very nice it's very beautiful
it's it's i mean it's it's so clean i
mean it's it's really you know and it
it tells one okay so anyway so then then
this
this branchial space uh has this sort of
map
of the the entanglements between quantum
states
so in physical space we have so so you
know you can say
you take let's say the causal graph and
we can slice that
uh at a particular time and then we get
this map of how things are laid out in
physical space
when we do the same kind of thing
there's a thing called the multi-way
causal graph which is the analog of a
causal graph for the multi-wave system
we slice that we get essentially the
relationships between things not in
physical space
but in the space of quantum states it's
like which quantum state is similar to
which other quantum state
okay so now i think next thing to say is
just to mention how quantum measurement
works
so quantum measurement has to do with
reference frames in branchial space
so okay so measurement in in physical
space
it matters whether how we assign
spatial position and how we how we
define coordinates in space and time
and that's that's how we make
measurements in ordinary space are we
making a measurement based on us sitting
still here
are we traveling at half the speed of
light and making measurements that way
these are different reference frames in
which we're making our measurements
and the relationship between different
events
and different points in space and time
uh
will be different depending on what
reference frame we're in
okay so then we have this idea of
quantum observation frames
which are the analog of reference frames
but in branchial space
and so what happens is what we realize
is that a quantum measurement
is the the observer is sort of
arbitrarily determining this reference
frame
the observer is saying i'm going to
understand the world
by saying that space and time are
coordinated this way
i'm going to understand the world by
saying that quantum states
and time are coordinated in this way and
essentially what happens is
that you know the process of quantum
measurement is a process
of deciding how you slice up this
multi-way system in these quantum
observation frames
so in a sense the observer the way the
observer enters
is by their choice of these quantum
observation frames
and what happens is that the observer um
because okay this is again another stack
of other concepts but anyway
because the observer is computationally
bounded
there is a limit to the type of quantum
observation frames that they can
construct
interesting okay so there's okay so some
constraints some limit on
another on the choice of observation
frames
right and by the way i just want to
mention that there's a i mean
it's bizarre but there's a hierarchy of
these things so in
um uh in thermodynamics the
the fact that we believe entropy
increases we believe things get more
disordered
as a consequence of the fact that we
can't track each individual molecule if
we could track every single molecule
we could run every movie in reverse so
to speak and we would you know
that we would not see that things are
getting more disordered but it's because
we are computationally bounded
we can only look at these big blobs of
what all these molecules collectively do
that we think that things are that we
describe it in terms of entropy
increasing and so on
and it's the same phenomenon basically
uh also
consequence of computational
irreducibility that causes us
to basically be forced to conclude that
definite things happen in the world
even though there's this quantum you
know this set of all these different
quantum processes that are going on
so i i mean i'm i'm i'm i'm skipping a
little bit and the
the but that that's a that's a rough
picture and
in the evolution of the wolfram physics
project where do you feel
stand on the some of the puzzles that
are along the way so you're skipping
along a bunch of
you know it's amazing how much these
things are unraveling i mean
you know these things look it used to be
the case that i would
agree with dick feynman nobody
understands quantum mechanics including
me
okay i'm getting to the point where i
think i actually understand quantum
mechanics my my exercise okay
is can i explain quantum mechanics for
real
at the level of kind of middle school
type explanation
right and i'm getting closer it's
getting it's getting there i'm not quite
there i've tried it a few times
and i realized that there are things
that um uh where i have to start talking
about elaborate mathematical concepts
and so on but i think
and you've got to realize that's not
self-evident that we can explain
you know at an intuitively graspable
level
something which uh you know about the
way the universe works the universe
wasn't built
for our understanding so to speak um but
but i think
then then um uh okay so another
important
important idea is um uh this idea of
branchial space which i mentioned this
sort of space of quantum states
it is okay so i mentioned einstein's
equations
describing you know the effect of
uh the effect of mass and energy
on uh trajectories of particles on gd6
the curvature of um a physical space
is associated with uh the presence of
energy according to einstein's equations
okay so it turns out that rather
amazingly the same thing is true
in bronchial space so it turns out the
presence of energy
or more accurately lagrangian density
which is a kind of relativistic
invariant version of energy the presence
of that
causes essentially deflection of gd6
in this branchial space okay so you
might say so what
well turns out that the sort of the best
formulation we have of quantum mechanics
this the feminine path integral is
a thing that describes quantum processes
in terms of mathematics that
can be interpreted as well in quantum
mechanics the big thing is you get these
quantum amplitudes which are complex
numbers
that represent when you combine them
together represent probabilities of
things happening
and so the big story has been how do you
derive these quantum amplitudes
and people think these quantum
amplitudes they have a complex number
has you know real part and imaginary
part you can also think of it has a
magnitude and a phase
um and it um people have sort of thought
these quantum amplitudes have magnitude
and phase and you compute those together
turns out that magnitude the magnitude
and the phase come from completely
different places
the magnitude comes okay so what do you
how do you compute things in quantum
mechanics roughly
i'm telling you i'm i'm getting there to
be able to do this at a middle school
level but i'm not there yet
um the the roughly what happens is
you're asking
does this state in quantum mechanics
evolve to this other state in quantum
mechanics and you can think about that
like a particle traveling or something
traveling through physical space
but instead it's traveling through
branchial space and so what's happening
is does this quantum state
evolve to this other quantum state it's
like saying does this object move from
this place in space to this other place
in space
okay now the way that you these quantum
amplitudes
characterize kind of um to what extent
the thing will successfully reach some
particular point in branchial space just
like
in physical space you could say oh it
had a certain velocity and it went in
this direction
in branch shield space there's a similar
kind of concept is there a nice way to
visualize
uh for me now mentally branchial space
it's just you have this hypograph
sorry you have this multi-way graph it's
this big branching thing branching and
merging thing but i mean
like moving through that space i i'm
just trying to understand
what that looks like you know that
space is probably exponential
dimensional which makes it
again another kind of worms and
understanding what's going on
that space as in in ordinary space
this hypergraph the spatial hypergraph
limits to something which is
like a manifold like a like something
like three dimensional space
almost certainly the multi-way graph
limits to a hilbert's base which is
something that
i mean it's it's just a weirder
exponential dimensional space
and by the way you can ask i mean there
are much weirder things that go on for
example one of the things i've been
interested in is
the expansion of the universe in
bronchial space so we know the universe
is expanding in physical space
but the universe is probably also
expanding
so that means the the number of quantum
states of the universe is increasing
with time
the diameter of the thing is growing
right so that means that the
and and by the way uh this is related to
whether quantum computing can ever work
um and uh why okay so let me explain why
so
so let's talk about okay so first of all
just just to finish the thought about
quantum amplitudes
the the incredibly beautiful thing that
just this is just
i'm just very excited about this the the
um the fine
path integral is is this formula it says
that the amplitude the quantum amplitude
is e to the i s over h bar
where s is the thing called the action
and um
it uh okay so that can be thought of
as representing a deflection of the
angle
of this path in the multi-way graph so
it's a deflection of a judicial in the
multi-wave path
that is caused by this thing called the
action which is essentially associated
with energy
okay and so this is a deflection of a
path in bronze hill space
that is described by this path integral
which is the thing that is the
mathematical essence of quantum
mechanics
turns out that deflection is
the deflection of gd6 in branch hill
space follows the exact same
mathematical setup as the deflection of
gd6 and physical space
except the deflection of gd6 and
physical space is described with
einstein's equations
the deflection of gd6 in shield space is
defined by the feynman path integral
and they are the same in other words
they are mathematically
the same so that means that general
relativity
is a story of essentially motion and
physical space
uh quantum mechanics is a story of
essentially motion and branchial space
and the underlying equation
for those two things although it's
presented differently because one's
interested in different things in rancho
space and physical space
but the underlying equation is the same
so in other words
it's the this it's just you know these
two theories which are the two sort of
pillars of 20th century physics
which have seemed to be off in different
directions are actually facets of the
exact
same theory there and this i mean
that's exciting to see to see where that
evolves and exciting that that just
is there right i mean to me you know
look i
having spent some part of my early life
you know working in these
in the context of these theories of you
know 20th century physics
it's they just they seem so different
and the fact that they're really the
same
it's just really amazing actually let me
you mentioned double [ __ ] experiment
okay so the double [ __ ] experiment is a
is an interference phenomenon where you
say there are
you know you can have a photon or an
electron and you say there are these two
slits it could have gone through either
one
but there is this interference pattern
where it's there's destructive
interference where
you might have said in classical physics
oh well if if there are two slits
then there's a better chance that it
gets through one or the other of them
but in quantum mechanics there's this
phenomenon of destructive interference
that means that even though there are
two slits two can lead to nothing
as opposed to two leading to more than
than
for example one slit and in what happens
in this model we've just been
understanding this in the last few weeks
actually
is that the um what essentially happens
is that the the double slit experiment
is a story of the interface between
branchial space and physical space
and what's essentially happening is that
the destructive interference is the
result
of the two possible paths associated
with photons going through those two
slits
winding up at opposite ends of bronchial
space and so they don't
and so that's why there's sort of
nothing there when you look at it
is because these two different sort of
branches
couldn't get merged together to produce
something that you can measure
in physical space is there a lot to be
understood about branchial space
i guess mathematically speaking
yes it's a very beautiful mathematical
thing and it's very
i mean by the way this whole theory is
just amazingly rich in terms of the
mathematics that it says
should exist okay so for example
calculus
you know is the story of infinitesimal
change
in integer dimensional space
one-dimensional two-dimensional
three-dimensional space
we need a theory of infinitesimal change
in fractional dimensional and dynamic
dimensional space
no such theory exists so there's uh
tools and mathematics that are needed
here right and this is the motivation
for that actually right and it's it's
you know there are there are indications
and we can do computer experiments and
we can see how it's going to come out
but we need to you know that the actual
mathematics is doesn't doesn't exist
and in branchial space it's actually
even worse there's there's even more
sort of layers of mathematics that
are you know we can see how it works
roughly by doing computer experiments
but to really understand it we need more
more sort of mathematical sophistication
you